18.30 dienstbeginn auf der rettungswache
tobias fila ist angehender
notfallsanitäter vor ihm und seinem
ausbildungsleiter markus müller liegt
eine zwölfstündige schicht mit dabei ein
pfefferspray offiziell zur tier abwehr
heute ist samstag keine beliebte schicht
also am wochenende fährt man nachts
meistens mehr weil die weil die leute am
wochenende gerne feiern gehen mit dem
alkoholpegel steigt auch das risiko für
übergriffe
die nachricht über funk bewusstlose frau
vor einem supermarkt mehr informationen
gibt es selten eine wahl haben die
rettungssanitäter nicht erst mal nur
noch mit die patientin covert am boden
ihr begleiter hat offensichtlich drogen
genommen ihnen geht alles viel zu
langsam
jetzt lassen so lassen sich doch erst
mal mit ihm sprechen ja damit ich
überhaupt erst mal mit ihr reden kann
und dann gehen wir zusammen ins auto und
da ist immer ein bisschen aber ein
bisschen mehr ruhe und dann kann man in
gesprächen in seminaren haben die
notfallhelfer gelernt wie man
deeskaliert auch das zurückziehen in den
rettungswagen ist eine bewusste
strategie erstmal reden wir aber sie
haben doch jetzt uns gerufen und jetzt
müssen wir doch erst mal miteinander
reden kann das auch ein routineeinsatz
schnell eskalieren kann hat tobias
fehler selbst erlebt vor eineinhalb
jahren wurden sie zum bahnhof gerufen
ein bewusstloser mann als der patient zu
sich kam griff er sie an
bei dem übergriff mit tobias fehler fast
auf die gleise wie nahe er dem tod war
begriff er erst später
so nach einem halben dreiviertel jahr
kamen diese bilder wirklich wieder hoch
was da so passiert ist und dann war ich
fünf wochen auch erst mal nicht im
dienst man hat gemerkt dass man nicht
mehr schlafen kann wenn man geschlafen
hatte kam genau diese bilder wieder hoch
dass sich die übergriffe häufen hat mit
einer neuen erwartungshaltung zu tun
wann beruf den rettungsdiensten die
haben das zu tun was wir möchten und
wenn das nicht so gemacht wird wie die
menschen die uns ein hilfeersuchen
entgegen kriegen wenn wir das nicht so
tun dann kann es auch relativ schnell in
gewalt umschlagen oder aggression
[Musik]
der nächste einsatz
sechs polizisten gegen einen mann im
drogenrausch
der mann hatte möbel aus dem fenster
geworfen als die polizei eintraf sprang
er hinterher ecstasy oder kokain
vermuten die einsatzkräfte
und dann ist da noch extrem aggressiv
ist durch die polizei mit handfesten
gefesselt
der patient wird nicht auf die
einsatzkräfte zu bespucken transport in
die notaufnahme
die polizisten fahren mit ok ohne
polizei ihre markus müller alleine mit
dem patienten
nach zehn stunden dienst zeit für einen
kaffee privat ist markus miller
kampfsportler die kollegen fragen im
scherz warum er nicht eingriffen
das ist nicht unser job dafür die
polizei wegen ist es oftmals so dass die
kollegen sich relativ viel gefallen
lassen bis die polizei hinzu geholt wird
oder auch dass man sich verteidigt warte
die hemmschwelle von unseren
mitarbeitern tochter sehr hoch ist
sieben uhr morgens schichtende
angespuckt gekribbelt und bedroht doch
die 112 glänzt